if somebody told me that they were about
to launch every single nuclear weapon on
the planet unless you kill an innocent
person would you kill the innocent
person the point of these questions is
in many ways to demonstrate that there
is no answer to these questions or at
least that if you have an answer there's
no way to really settle the question in
your favor
alex o'connor welcome to the show chris
williamson thank you so much for having
me again yes again thank you for joining
me here in austin how is he philosophy
graduate
youtuber podcaster and now wake surfing
extraordinaire yeah my wrists feel as
though they're about to come off um i i
don't think i've ever used this
particular muscle
before that's a lie we both know that
that's a lie
[Laughter]
yeah well certainly not uh certainly not
this yeah
um
yesterday
you turned up to a boat trip
wearing a pretty similar outfit to the
one that you're in today yes i i'm i'm
trying to live out the philosophy that
there is no situation in which you can't
wear
something resembling a suit maybe you
have to leave the jacket at home maybe
out of push i was just a little bit warm
but shirt chinos it's about as casual as
it gets you you did good yesterday i
can't believe you've shown up to a
philosophical conversation wearing a
t-shirt and shorts well i mean this is
my uniform you know
yeah well well we're hopefully by the
end of this we're going to be much more
philosophically entwined and you'll
begin to understand how fun it is to be
a bit pretentious about these matters
always dress formally quite right okay
uh so the last time that we spoke on the
show we were talking about some moral
quandaries and some ethical dilemmas and
i really enjoyed that i like the
opportunity to do thought experiments it
means that people can have their brains
fried at home as well as me problem
being that i am the one that is publicly
the most stupid right when these
questions get asked and you say what
would you what do you mean by kindness
and then i have to try and think of
something uh so
go gentle with me today is is my request
i'll try my best but there's i mean the
implication that i'm any better is is a
mistaken one i think the point of these
questions
is in many ways to demonstrate that
there is no answer to these questions or
at least that if you have an answer
there's no way to really settle the
question in your favor we don't really
have a better grasp of
the good or the just city than did plato
and the ancients we haven't really
progressed very much and so it seems a
bit
futile to be discussing this kind of
stuff
but as they say the whys of every
generation discover the same truths
these if there is such thing as moral
truth it seems to be something that's
out there and graspable by individuals
as they go throughout their life it's
not going to put you in a better place
than any of your ancestors but it will
put you in a better place than you were
yourself a few years ago so they're
still worth
asking and answering to see what you
think about these things but don't
expect to become a moral expert it was a
wonderful
question uh on an exam paper
for uh when i was studying philosophy
and theology um
i can't remember i think it was on the
ethics paper it must have been and i
can't remember the exact wording but the
question was something like does
studying ethics
make you
an expert in ethics or does it make you
a better person or something like this
and if not what's the point
because of course you can study ethical
theories you can have an answer to every
single ethical query but is that going
to make you a better person in many ways
it might make you a worse person
you're more able to rationalize yourself
out of uh
moral obligation you're able to get away
with things just by convincing yourself
somehow that they're ethical because
you've got all of these ethical
theories running around your head my
experience is that
i i have a i have a much better
understanding
of my own moral intuitions it feels like
i kind of get to know myself when i
study what's actually going on in my
brain when i think something is wrong
it's a very distinct feeling in your
brain it's distinct from anxiety or
sadness or anger it's distinct from
propositions like this chair exists it's
a very specific feeling it's like trying
to pin down what that is what its nature
is what it's grasping at helps you to
know yourself a bit better but i don't
think it helps you to act upon them any
more strongly daniel kahneman that wrote
thinking fast and slogan asked by sam
harris on stage after all of these years
learning about cognitive biases and how
irrational the human mind is has it made
you
any less prone to falling prey to these
things daniel thought about it for a
second
no not really you know okay well it
seems like the people that spend a lot
of their time thinking about this stuff
understand it a lot better but that it
does seem to be uh very ingrained just
going back to the the wise of every
generation discover the same truth which
is a great quote
why do you think it is that we need to
rediscover the same truths why is it
that
in the same way as technology you know
we're not rediscovering the wheel we're
improving upon the wheel and iterating
on top of it why is it that
it does seem a little bit like the same
questions get asked and an
unsatisfactory answer comes back
that's that's an important question um i
i don't think it's always the case that
it's unsatisfactory some people are
perfectly satisfied in the ethical
conclusions that they come to it's just
that they're not going to be universally
accepted um
i suppose
with with something like the scientific
method
you have this process of learning you
have this this building block that you
have to teach to the next generation and
then they build upon it and that's the
idea
and every generation gets taught those
building blocks a bit
more quickly for that reason you learn a
bit more at high school level because
science has progressed that the people
at phd levels are going a bit further
and putting a bit more icing on the cake
ethics can't really do this i mean it
can people are doing phds all over the
world in very specific
as of yet sort of undiscussed ethical
dilemmas and qualms and areas but
realistically
it's because coming to terms with ethics
is very much
in many ways a journey of self-discovery
and so it's kind of like how
everybody in each generation will need
to learn uh how to live with themselves
in in their lives and people are kind of
coming to terms with the person that
they are trying to figure out how best
to live their life trying to figure out
how to be happy this isn't something you
can just learn and then teach to your
children it's something they have to
discover for themselves it seems to be
something a lot more personal it's
informed by experience it's informed by
intuition if you're talking to somebody
about an ethical issue you might find
that their views on an ethical issue are
almost entirely dependent upon the
experiences that they've had at the very
least they'll be heavily affected by it
if you're talking about the the ethics
of theft with somebody who used to be
homeless and used to steal in order to
feed their family they're probably going
to have a different idea of of what it
means to thieve of the ethics of
thievery and this kind of thing of
course ideally it wouldn't be this way
because we'd be able to
detach ourselves from experience and
think hyper rationally about ethics but
this is one of the reasons i've come to
think that ethic i subscribe to a view
called ethical emotivism that ethics is
just an expression of emotion which i
think ties in very well
with this uh observation
and so if that's what's going on when
we're doing ethics then it makes sense
that it's not something you can just
teach to somebody else in a book it's
something that has to be lived
why is ethics an expression of emotions
well there are there are there are lots
of reasons for this i mean the the
emotivist position is really not so much
a meta ethical theory of what
good itself is but rather what's going
on in someone's head when they say that
something is good or when they say that
something is bad it's it's a famously
difficult thing to define um
the the most famous case for emotivism
it's it's a theory that's actually kind
of gone out of fashion uh of of late it
was originally put forward by aj ayer in
the 20th century in a groundbreaking
book called language truth and logic
which stated that
the only things that can be meaningful
are those which are either empirically
verifiable
you can prove them by observation or
things which are just analytically true
like that there are no married bachelors
that that's just tautologically true you
don't need to go and observe every
single bachelor to know that they're
unmarried these are the only things that
can be meaningful someone came along and
well it was ai himself preempting the
objection comes along and says well what
about ethical claims these seem to be
meaningful people seem to mean something
when they say murder is wrong but it's
not empirically verifiable that murder
is wrong what are you observing what is
it about murder where is this quality of
wrongness within an action that doesn't
really make sense but it's also not
analytically true it doesn't follow
logically from murder that murder is
wrong it's not a tautology so
it's meaningless right and aya thinks
well maybe there's something else going
on maybe when someone says murder is
wrong what they're really saying is
something like boo murder crudely
so for air writing murder is wrong is
basically the same to write as writing
murder
followed by an exclamation mark in an
angry emoji it doesn't add any
propositional content it's just an
expression and this is emotivism but
there are other forms of non-cognitivism
the idea that ethical statements are not
cognitive
they're not true or false in the way
generally thought of because of course
emotions expressions of emotions can't
be true or false
some people think that rather than being
something like boo murder it's more like
don't murder that when you say murder is
wrong you're expressing something like
don't murder
that can't be true or false
don't murder isn't true nor is it false
likewise boo murder is not true or false
it doesn't have truth value it's just an
expression this is the emotivist
position and i just think that it offers
a better account of what's going on in
people's heads
if they pay attention to to the to the
basis of their ethical intuitions it
seems just to be
at root some form of expression the
rationalization that goes on the kind of
well
premise premise conclusion well if we
accept this theory this entails this
conclusion and this is you know sure
there's all that going on but it's all
based upon an expression of emotion look
at how much of look out so much of
ethical decision making or i should say
like the the solving of dilemmas if you
take like the utilitarian position that
the best thing to do is to maximize
pleasure famous criticism of
utilitarianism is well would you be in
favor of uh killing five oh sorry
killing one person to harvest their
organs because you've got five other
people who need each organ in order to
survive they need an organ transplant
but no one's there to give it to them
but you've got this one guy who walks in
and he's got all the organs so we kill
the one person give it to the five
of course there are answers to this
there are answers to why this might be
wrong even on utilitarianism but the
basic idea is like well you wouldn't do
that right
like that would be that would be
terrible that would be horrible and so
the theory must be wrong
but on what grounds are you saying that
because utilitarianism commits us to the
view that we should be killing one
person to save five
so
like why is that a criticism of
utilitarianism
well it's only because when you hear
that example when you hear what it leads
to you have this feeling of kind of like
no
don't do that boo that something
something like that and you might think
well no actually you know the reason i
don't like that is because
it will actually contribute to like fear
in society because people will be scared
that they're going to have their organs
it's like okay like
so like why don't you like that
ultimately i think it all breaks down to
something if you pay attention to the to
the nature of the feeling in your head
it's something that belongs in the
category of emotion it's just something
like
ew or gross or no or boo
something like this it's not one of
those things common misconception of
emotivism ethical claims don't map on to
emotions like anxiety and sadness and
boo
rather
they just belong in that category but
it's its own unique feeling i think
ethics
imagine we lived in a world chris where
there was no word for anxiety
she didn't have a word for it
it's like okay so someone feels this
thing anxiety and they're trying to
describe what it is that they're feeling
they're like well it's kind of like it's
kind of like being it's kind of like
excited but sad
and
like bad at the same time it's like bad
exciting they'd be kind of dancing
around they're saying it's not quite
this but it's a bit like this a bit like
this is kind of somewhere in the middle
and there's this very unique feeling
that we have
towards
in the way that we might feel anxious
towards public speaking or sad towards
the death of a friend there's a very
unique feeling that we have
towards seeing somebody steal from a
homeless man
what is it well it's kind of like
oh it's kind of like disgust it's kind
of like boo it's kind of like don't it's
kind it's kind of a bit like that but
it's but it's not any one of those
things it's somewhere in the middle and
we don't have a word for it well i just
think that we do have a word for it and
that word is wrong but then it belongs
in that category of thought it's just
it's just
within that uh
that that that context and and that's
how we should understand ethical
statements but that's my view the last
time we spoke
you seem to think that ethics was uh
essentially a project of minimizing
suffering i wonder if that's still an
intuition that you hold to
that was the intuition i've got and
i feel like you're now making me commit
to some ridiculous thought experiment
that you're about to put in front of me
and say well
that's interesting because if we're
going to try and minimize suffering then
dot dot what the premise of our
conversation chris was that you wanted
me to bring along some ethical
quandaries for us to work through
together and hopefully finally after
thousands of years put to bed
um
i just think it's a good way to to start
thinking about ethics to look at some
some
you know case examples let's get it
there's a wonderful
uh if we take this kind of utilitarian
position of minimizing suffering and the
reason it's good to start there is
because at least in a secular context
most people
start here most people think ethics is
something about minimizing suffering or
maximizing pleasure that is
the thing that is right
is the action which minimizes suffering
or maximizes pleasure maybe these are
the same thing this is the utilitarian
position at least one version of it the
crude utilitarian
so there's a there's a wonderful thought
experiment um
which comes from roger crisp who is
uh who has a wonderful
um
review and analysis of john stuart mills
utilitarianism it's a it's if you're
trying to read utilitarianism by mill
it's worth reading roger crisp alongside
him it's just the best kind of
introduction
to it and and it's the it's the book
that was set for all undergraduates to
read at oxford as well um philosophy
undergraduates he he comes up with this
example which he calls the rash doctor
uh so imagine for a second that that
there's there's a doctor
and there's
a patient that he needs to treat that's
in pretty dire need maybe they're at the
you know on the on the brink of death or
something and the doctor has two options
there's like pill a and pill b the red
pill in the blue
pill a and pill b the pill a is one
where if administered
it has
a 99 chance of failure call it a 99.9
chance of failure it's just going to
kill the patient in terrible agony
but it has a 0.1 chance of restoring him
to perfect health
that's pill one pill b
pill two
whatever b1 i don't care
is a pill that is basically
the reverse such that it has a 99.9
chance of success
but it will only restore the patient to
let's say 95 health so still pretty good
you know like a perfectly livable life
just not quite 100 but but nothing that
would be complained about
and it has a 0.1 percent chance of
failure and killing them painlessly and
agonizingly
okay so these are the two options now
the doctor chooses
the first pill
the one that's going to have this this
overwhelming probability of agonizingly
killing the man
but it works
and it restores them to 100 health did
the doctor do the right thing
is the question
in retrospect
it depends on
whether you could have run the
experiment again
can we do this again can we see what
would have happened problem being that
you're never going to actually get to
split test this
experiment and work out whether or not
you would have killed him with pill b
it ends up being
probabilistic utilitarianism exactly and
so what we end up with is a situation i
mean i think most people would want to
say that the doctor should choose pill b
it seems
clear to most people
again might be a class of intuitions but
if you have these two pills
99 chance of certain death 1 chance of
100 health versus 99 chance of of like
95 or even like 99 health and only a
tiny slim chance of killing the patient
surely the second one is the right one
to do but of course if we say that the
right thing to do is that which
maximizes pleasure or that which
minimizes suffering
then we'd be committed to the view that
if he chose pill b
even if it works if pill a would have
worked he did the wrong thing
which seems weird
seems like we want to say that there's
some sense in which you should choose
the second and as you quite rightly
identify we should be probabilistic
about this this is where you can
distinguish between actualist
utilitarianism and probabilistic
utilitarianism so maybe what we should
do is not what actually maximizes
pleasure but what will probably maximize
pleasure but then that's a little
strange because
if the reason why we're trying to
maximize pleasure or minimize suffering
is because we believe that there's just
something about suffering there's
something there's this moral truth of
the universe that minimizing suffering
is the right thing to do
like what right do we have to add this
probabilistic qualifier to it except
because it's kind of practically
difficult to
to swallow that pill
if you will
it's like
okay well we're just kind of letting our
practical considerations what override
our considerations about the very nature
of good and pleasure itself that doesn't
seem quite right can we just say that
what is good is what will probably
maximize pleasure that doesn't seem like
a very steadfast sort of
rule of the very precise is it so maybe
then we need to distinguish between the
the criterion of the good and the
decision procedure
that is the criterion of the of right
that the
thing that makes something good is still
what actually maximizes pleasure it's
just that the best way on the whole to
achieve that
is to adopt in our decision procedure
that is when deciding how to make uh
ethical choices to take a probabilistic
approach
so probably maximizing pleasure isn't
the criterion of good
but it is the
procedure that we use to make the
decision about how to get to the
criterion of good which is still
actual
maximization of pleasure but
you can see already that it can't be as
simple as kind of or the right thing to
do is that which maximizes pleasure i
mean there's a whole other problem with
this which is that
of course if if you want to be a
utilitarian that
that kind of crudely decides in any
situation the best thing to do is what's
going to maximize pleasure even probably
so it means that every time you go to
make a decision you have to do this kind
of
moral calculus a hedonic calculus and
figure out what's going to
what's going to have the best effect
here but what if it's the case that the
act of doing the hedonic calculus
is actually more harmful
well then you shouldn't do the hedonic
calculus
but that means that you're kind of then
not acting like a utilitarian what would
be an example of that well just for
instance i mean if you were kind of
i don't know if if you were if you had
to make a quick split ethical decision
like an emt
sure that's got some people by the side
of the road and you need to work out and
by taking the time to do the hedonic
calculus more suffering is
yeah like you maybe you don't even have
time to do it there it's like if the
right thing to do is always to kind of
analyze the situation and see what's
going to maximize pleasure in that
situation by doing the analysis you run
out of time and the patient's dead yes
um
also maybe even in kind of mild cases
because an interesting consequence of
utilitarianism is that there's almost no
such thing as an amoral action because
everything seems to have some minimal
effect on pleasure and suffering you
know the position that i'm sat in seems
to at least minimally affect the
pleasure i'm feeling the suffering that
i'm having you know that my tone of
voice towards you like every single
little
minute decision seems to be something
that has some minimal effect on pleasure
and suffering and so
sure you could you could say that every
single time i do anything i'm going to
do a hedonic calculus but then you
basically become paralyzed becomes very
difficult and slow to do absolutely
anything and so
in that second case it's not
it's not like the first where it's
obvious that just doing the calculus
makes you run out of time in this case
like there's nothing in principle
stopping you from doing it you could
just try to make sure that every single
time you do anything you think carefully
about the the effect on pleasure but
that just doesn't seem like a very good
way to live it seems like it's quite
harmful to a person and overall might
actually be more annoying to people
might cause more suffering and so
okay so what if it's the case that
living as a utilitarian
is wrong by a utilitarian standard
and should we be utilitarians well if we
should then utilitarian
the utilitarian ethic dictates that we
don't always live by utilitarianism in
this way
so let's not
so it kind of self-defeats
now
there are more ways around this of
course so this is where you get
something like rule utilitarianism which
says that the best way uh the the way to
kind of get to the good the way to
maximize pleasure is to adopt rules
which if generally followed will
maximize pleasure
and so you come up with rules like
don't murder
don't thieve and so even in a situation
where
it might actually minimize suffering for
you to thieve in this particular
situation it's like because we've
already abandoned this idea of judging
every situation on its individual merits
we say we don't have time for that we're
just gonna we're just gonna have a rule
and if we generally follow this rule
pleasure gets maximized and so even in a
situation where
thieving say would actually minimize
suffering
you should still not do it because of
your allegiance to this rule
but then that seems weird too right
because now you've got a situation where
you might well know because you've done
the hedonic calculus you've worked out
that yeah in this situation if i were to
you know
a famous example might be if you're a
sheriff of a town
and there's an innocent man but the
whole town thinks that he's guilty and
they're gonna cause an absolute riot and
just burn the city down if he's set free
but you know that he's innocent it's
like
well sending that man to jail even
though he's innocent will minimize
suffering in this instance because it
prevents the whole city burning down
it's like okay what should we do here
well degree of injustice that's going on
that feels like it's outside of the sort
of utilitarian outcome yes so justice is
one of the biggest criticisms of of
utilitarianism the idea that there seems
to be this thing called justice you have
this right that is impenetrable even by
the the persuasive force of
great deals of suffering even that has
its limits of course most people would
say that you could you know kill an
innocent person if it was going to stop
a nuclear war from going off that
destroys the entire planet it's like why
did you believe in rights in the first
place
if you actually believe that there are
these things called rights which are
genuinely inviolable
then you have to commit yourself to the
view that that right can't be violated
even in the situation where you know
it's going to prevent a disaster and if
you say well no no then okay in that
situation it'd be okay to violate the
right there was no right in the first
place it was just this rule that you
made up that you think on the whole is
going to minimize pleasure
minimize suffering but you can see in an
obvious case where this is definitely
going to maximize suffering you just
violate the right it betrays this idea
of a right as nothing more
than one of the rules of rule
utilitarianism
is there a
is there a way to
try and have broad rules that for the
majority of cases
are
useful
um and then
ignore the outliers so i know that the
last time we spoke you explained is it
the reductio ad absurdum where you try
and do something which
shows if you take this particular
ethical
theory to an extreme case something kind
of weird or bizarre happens at the
entire town getting burned down to
put one man in jail as an example
is there a way that people have tried in
ethics to say well look
on average most cases are going to fall
within this bell curve
of normalcy there might be some outliers
but that doesn't necessarily disprove
the fact that overall this seems to be
an optimal way to do things
well yes of course there have been
attempts and the reductio ad absurdum is
a useful approach just means reduction
to absurdity it shows well let's take
this logic see where it goes and see if
it leads to absurdity
the reason why people do a reductio is
because
if you put forward this principle that
the issue with something like
utilitarianism is it's often put forward
as an objective moral theory that is it
is objectively true
that this is
what should be done you could be kind of
a subjective utilitarian that thinks
that pleasure is only subjectively good
or something like this mill himself
certainly thought it was objectively
true in the way that uh the fact that i
can see a table as evidence that it's
there
um or that rather it's a little more
subtle than that but similarly the fact
that i desire pleasure proves that it's
desirable
in the way that the table being visible
proves that i can see it
so
he thinks that it's objective and the
problem is if you have an objective
theory if you're saying this is just
objectively true even if you find a
single example no matter how convoluted
it proves it wrong or that makes us
think it's wrong
it must be wrong imagine if we did the
same thing with mathematics imagine if
we had a mathematical formula indeed in
history we've had this we've got like
newtonian physics is a famous famous
example very good you know newton really
had it going for him got us to the moon
and back
but
when it comes to like things moving
close to the speed of light or something
like this
it doesn't work
okay so
we could just kind of say well you know
newton gravity is kind of it's it's true
enough or it kind of works and it is in
practice in terms of its its practical
import yes it's good enough to help us
live but if we're talking about the
actual truth of it
it's not like yeah well i guess it's
it's it's kind of true it's like no if
something proves it wrong it means it's
false if we if we had a mathematical
formula that we thought was true
but
we showed an example of it punching out
an actually obviously false answer we
wouldn't just be like oh it's right most
of the time we'd be like this is how
science is done you try to disprove a
theory and if you find one example of
something disproving it the theory must
be wrong and so if we're going to try to
objectify
uh
ethics in this way we have to hold it to
the same standards it doesn't matter how
much of an outlier it is
if if you've proven it wrong you've
proven it wrong
lay it on me give me give me something
that's going to make me look stupid
um so here's a here's a fun way to
try to nail down the intuition is
whether you believe
whether you think like a utilitarian or
whether you think like a rights based
deontologist a person who believes that
there are these things called rights
that people have that are immune to
amounts of suffering and pleasure and
again we can get into that more because
of course we've kind of hinted at these
examples but the idea is that
if the thing that matters is suffering
and pleasure then if harming an innocent
person to save many people maximizes
pleasure
then we should be able to do it but
people want to say no there's this thing
called rights so they seem to contradict
each other mill tries to offer an
analysis a bit like what i just did of
saying that rights are actually kind of
a construct that comes out of
pleasure but it's it's generally thought
that he's a contradict each other so
there's a there's a wonderful uh
question that i once approached on on my
youtube channel and i want to read it
word for word to give it credit to the
place it came from which is a wonderful
quiz called morality play
um
it's i can't remember the website's name
but i'll send it to you maybe you can
link it in the description but i think
it's the first question i'll read it
word for word and see what you think of
this
you are able to help some people
but unfortunately you can only do so by
harming other people
the number of people harmed will always
be 10 of those helped
when considering whether it is morally
justified to help does the actual number
of people involved make any difference
for example does it make a difference if
you are helping 10 people by harming one
person rather than helping a hundred
thousand people by harming ten thousand
people
in other words is the moral
analysis the same the proportions are
exactly the same
you're always kind of
uh you're always saving ten times the
amount of people that you're harming
but is there a moral difference
in let's say killing one innocent person
to save ten and killing ten thousand
save a hundred thousand even if you
think both are wrong even if you think
both are justified
are they exactly equal are they equally
justified or wrong so my intuition is
that the bigger numbers feel more wrong
it feels like there's more overall
suffering going on
if you say you have the choice between
suffering for ten thousand people but
pleasure for a hundred thousand versus
suffering for one and pleasure for ten
the one for ten to me seems
more acceptable than the bigger number
you say there's more suffering going on
which there is but there's also much
more pleasure going on that the point of
the thought experiment is that these
equally balance out so in in both cases
the balance of suffering and pleasure is
precisely the same
proportionally yeah it's equally kind of
cancelled out and so yeah you increase
the suffering a lot but you also
increase the pleasure so that the
balance remains exactly the same
so if what you care about is the
minimization of suffering or the getting
the getting the best balance of pleasure
over suffering then these two ought to
be the same right
yes they should be but i'm obviously
logically inconsistent well maybe you
feel like it's worse to harm more people
to save more people i think we've had
this discussion before that um
the avoidance of suffering rather than
the pursuit of pleasure is an
interesting question and also is the
pursuit of pleasure simply the absence
of suffering there seems to be a good
bit of evidence that suggests that
humans aren't actually pleasure seekers
they're suffering minimizers yes you can
kind of reject the grammar of the
question by saying that i mean the
implication in the question is that the
proportions remain the same but is it
worse maybe you could just say the
proportions don't remain the same one
way to uh to
establish this conclusion is to say that
like david benatar does the famous
anti-natalist who who wrote a wonderful
book called better never to have been
that has a wonderful discussion on the
nature of suffering and pleasure and
their asymmetry it's not just an
argument as to why you shouldn't have
kids it's it contains a lot of wonderful
reflections on these on these topics
and he thinks that suffering just counts
for more yep would you take five minutes
of the worst suffering imaginable if
afterwards you got five minutes of the
greatest pleasure imaginable
hard to say but most people say no it's
kind of not worth it
in a way do you remember when we went to
the life lessons festival a couple of
years ago and we were sat down it was a
canteen style thing at some disgustingly
ugly building in the middle of london
and the barbican that was a dreaded
barbecue yeah it's some sort of
brutalist architectural nightmare
evil
correct yeah exactly and uh we were sat
down at the canteen sort of a school
table style thing long benches we were
having this exact discussion about uh
the relative amounts of suffering and
pleasure it's before you became a
full-on nihilist but i think he would it
was a gateway drug genialism and uh
people kept on coming and going people
would sit down next to us recognize you
or recognize me or just sit near us and
i don't know whether you noticed but
there was
an increasing um sort of like no-go zone
that people sort of came sat down
look didn't like the conversation and
then sort of shuffled away or just left
very quickly yeah well it can be
morbidly fascinating but it's also quite
depressing to think about
benes book is is
uh it
the first chapter or maybe the second
uh is arguing that even if your life is
mostly pleasure
and just a little bit of suffering it's
still not worth beginning it's still not
worth having a bringing a child into
existence that's that's going to have
mostly pleasure and only a little bit of
suffering but then the next chapter
after convincing of that conclusion or
trying to the next chapter is basically
him saying
but even so your life definitely is way
more suffering than pleasure and i'm
about to prove it to you it's it's not
the name of the chapter but it's the
essence of it is why your life is going
a lot worse than you even you think it
is and he kind of puts this real
emphasis on on the suffering uh and it
does seem like maybe there's a
there's an imbalance here it does seem
that there's a there's a difference in
the way that we treat them for example
i can i can unconsensually inflict
suffering upon you if it's going to
prevent greater suffering if you're like
if you're like unable to speak to me or
something there's something going on
with your with your communication
and i need to break your arm because if
i don't maybe you're like drowning in in
some small little like cave and and your
your arm stuck and i need to break your
arm to pull you out i'm justified in
doing that unconsensually
because suffering for more suffering is
fine
but if i could inflict suffering to
bring about some great pleasure in your
life if i were to break your arm and by
doing so give you like an encyclopedic
knowledge of philosophy that would just
be perfect for your podcast even if like
even if in theory you might actually
choose that if given the choice if it's
unconsensual
i don't have the right to do that in the
same way
why
why can i inflict suffering
unconsensually to prevent greater
suffering but i can't inflict suffering
unconsensually
to grant some really really great
pleasure that might even outweigh the
suffering it seems to be an imbalance it
seems like this is because of the
asymmetry between how we view pleasure
and how we view suffering quite but of
course you can just adopt thought
experiments uh adapt thought experiments
that's the wonderful thing about them so
if you think suffering counts for more
just imagine kind of whatever the
proportions would look like so
just just make it so that the balance is
actually the same so maybe one percent
instead of 10
or maybe maybe yeah maybe like killing
one to save 10 is roughly the same as
like i don't know killing
like 500 to save
ten thousand because maybe you need to
slightly adapt it you get a discount
when you
start to do it at scale as you pilot the
suffering its proportional impact needs
to be accounted for but even if that's
the case it's like just do that just say
that the proportions are the same
in you've got one situation in which you
kill
x to save you know
nx
and another situation in which you have
to in which you save kind of like a
bigger version of that
but the balance is the same
is it worse
and you can just ask the question again
or is it like as good
it's like
okay well if you're a utilitarian you
might want to think yes because the
balance is the same but there's
something about this which makes us
maybe want to say that
it would be worse to kill more innocent
people even to save
uh more people from harm
well maybe that's because there is this
thing called rights
maybe
people actually just do have this
property
that they have a they have a right not
to be violated now if you have a right
that is immune to the amount of
suffering this is what a right is it's
it's a it's a claim that's inviolable
it's a claim that you have against other
people it always comes along with the
correlative duty if i have a right it
means someone else has a duty
there are traditionally thought to be
four types of rights but the important
one is a
for this
uh discussion is a claim right it's like
it's a it's a kind of claim that i have
over you you have a duty not to harm me
if i have a right not to be harmed by
you it's always always comes in pairs
um
and the point of a right is that it's
inviolable which means that it doesn't
matter how much suffering it's going to
save you don't get to do that i can't i
can't kill you to steal your food to
donate it all to charity even if that's
going to save a bunch of children from
starvation you have a right to your
property you have a right to your life
and so i can't do that doesn't matter
what suffering's going on here
so if somebody has a right to life that
can't be violated then
it doesn't matter how many people are
being saved
a violation of that right's a bad thing
and so if i violate your right to save
one person or to save 10 people doesn't
make a difference can't violate it
so if i violate one right to save
10 people
it's like who cares how many people were
saving you've violated a right it
doesn't like it's immune to the
suffering that you're saving and so all
that we really care about in this
analysis is you violated one right
whereas if you
kill 10 people save 100 people
proportions are the same you violated 10
rights to save 100 who cares it's immune
to the suffering you violated 10 rights
so you violated 10 rights versus
violating one right and so it's worse so
maybe it would actually be worse because
you're violating rights in such a way
that's actually just immune to
considerations of of how much suffering
you're preventing
and sure you can take that view if you
like the problem with it for me of
course is that
if you
if you if you think that you just have
this thing called a right that that
can't be violated regardless of the
suffering that's being inflicted you
commit yourself to the view that if i
had a choice if somebody told me that
they were about to launch every single
nuclear weapon on the planet
unless you kill an innocent person
would you kill the innocent person
yes
if they have an inviolable claim right
not to be killed you can't do that you
have to let the world burn
but you're going to do that so maybe the
right actually isn't as inviolable as
you thought and maybe it actually is
sensitive to the amount of people that's
being saved this is a big difference
between doing and allowing right because
you could argue that by not killing that
person you're killing all of the other
people
well
i mean you you could argue that but it's
it's
i think you'd be
i think it's it's always a bit unfair to
characterize this kind of situation in
this way i mean
like if um
if
if a terrorist tells you that that
they're going to blow up manhattan
unless you you know torture your own
daughter or something like this
it seems to me that if you talk if you
believe in rights one approach is to say
that if you torture your daughter
like you have violated her rights you've
done something wrong
okay so if you don't touch your daughter
millions of people's rights will be
violated so even if you believe in
rights surely you should favor like one
right being violated minimization of
right violation exactly
but of course
depends how we're approaching ethics
what's the point of ethics maybe it's to
figure out what's the right thing for an
individual to do so what's the right
thing for you to do well
if you violate your daughter's rights
you violated a right if you don't then
millions of people's rights get violated
but not by you by the terrorist
you've allowed somebody else to violate
someone else's rights but that's not on
you you don't get any moral
blame-worthiness
for somebody else violating somebody
else's rights they're the ones who
violated the rights and
we kind of accept this line of thinking
when when we refuse to give in to
uh you know demands by hostages and this
kind of thing so they end up killing the
hostages that are making the demands
yeah
you know if it's bloody demanding
hostages we um well i imagine they
probably do get quite demanding at some
point
if if if the terrorist kind of says like
you know could you imagine could you
imagine you
being taken hostage by some terrorists
it would it would make for some sort of
fun ethical dilemmas maybe i can't point
being
into yeah that's that's it that they
would
throw you out and say please
please take him back they'd be like
they'd be like look listen we're gonna
kill you unless unless you do that and
i'd be kind of like yeah fair enough
yeah okay the words did you kind of i
kind of understand that but which which
i mean which ethical theory are you kind
of
are you abiding by that ballistic
utilitarianism they were like a
religious terrorist it's kind of like
well well which are you like a divine
command theorist you do you think the
evil is like a privatization get him out
get him sick of him like reverse
stockholm syndrome right what's next
give me give me give me something else
well let's see what else we've got uh
let's see what else we've got going on
um
okay here's here's just take a totally
different term uh turn i want to get
your your views and and calibrate your
intuitions on
the nature of of the relationship
between moral responsibility and the
ability to have acted differently
most people think
that generally speaking
if you are to be held morally
responsible for something you need to
have been able to act differently
um
if if you couldn't help but commit a
particular action then it's it's
difficult to hold you morally justified
uh morally uh responsible responsible
for that action uh there's a interesting
example that's often given in the
discussion of free will
it's discussed by sam harris in his free
will book i know that for a fact
of
this is a real case it was a man who
was basically exhibiting pedophilic
tendencies
he was just sexually attracted to
children
and i can't remember if he acted upon it
or not i think he may have done and so
the nurses in the place where he was
being held after a little while after he
submitted himself a psychological
evaluation psychic psychiatric
evaluation of course
when
the evaluation is done it's discovered
that there's this great tumor
that's pressing against the part of his
brain that deals with impulse control
okay how does this change your moral
assessment of this person you might
actually start feeling sorry for them
because it's as if i've kind of
if i were to like prod your brain chris
in such a way that gave you the same
disposition
i'd be doing a great evil to you you'd
be a victim there it's not it's not your
fault
it's like
okay cool um and the fact that there
isn't a prodder in this situation makes
it kind of unique because there's no
first mover that you can point to to say
that they're the person that calls this
stuff
there's no one there's no one kind of to
blame here and the way that kind of you
know somebody might be victimized by
cancer but there's there's not really
someone to blame for them developing it
it's just but it you know it's it's
something that we we feel sorry for
people who undergo this it's like okay
so this this person has a has a brain
tumor that's basically turning them into
a pedophile
okay do you feel sorry for this person i
mean i i
seem to i i would say yeah i mean this
is a horrible situation to be in and
they remove the tumor and
the disposition goes away
and then a little while later it comes
back this position starts coming back he
starts getting a bit pedo again bit
nancy and then
they discover that the tumors come back
okay
so we say this person
let's start with kind of the the the
attractive quality
that the the fact that this person has
this
their sexual attraction
certainly
it's not their fault that they that they
were this way because they had this
thing in their brain that was like
causing them to think this that was
through no control of their own but of
course this is just how sexual
attraction works anyway
it's just this thing in your brain that
makes you feel a particular way that you
can't control you don't get to choose
what you're attracted to the fact that
your inhibitions have been lowered yes
is
it's just a gradation right it's not a
difference of type it's simply a
difference of kind presumably everybody
has some degree of inhibition and some
degree of sexual attraction
and that those are pointed in different
directions i feel like it was his uh
stepdaughter
that was the
young girl that he'd sort of made some
movements towards so he annihilated his
own marriage top he died his own
marriage to this lady who who had this
daughter uh
maybe twice in fact i feel like she took
him back after the first tumor and then
it happened again and then she let him
go but it was it was tubes i mean even
that's interesting is there a number of
times
that your
non-conscious
inhibition reduction should be allowed
by a person
well
this is where i think it's very useful
to adopt something like uh susan wolf's
real self view
that is the difference between
determining whether somebody is like
responsible and we we remove the moral
element because we kind of remove
freedom here we should get there in a
second because we should we should make
sure kind of
everyone's at the at the same point here
it's like okay so we can probably agree
that
if somebody finds themselves
sexually attracted to children
you can't hold them morally responsible
for the sexual attraction
like
you can't choose what you're attracted
to if anything you feel sorry for such
people there's a great study that
a neuroscientist did where he got um
straight men straight women gay men gay
women people that are attracted to kids
people are attracted to animals put them
all into an mri and put an arousal
response meter around them which is a
basically a [ __ ] ring for man like a
moisture meter or something for women uh
put them in there and showed everybody
every different type of attractive image
and and video that they could and you
would think that especially in a
situation like this that people that
were attracted to kids would maybe try
and sort of
cha they would adapt what was going on
maybe out of embarrassment or something
like that
and it turns out that you can show them
absolutely everything under the sun
and they
don't get any response and this is
there's just generally a fascinating
intuition when it comes to people that
are attracted to kids that i asked him
do people get to choose what they're
attracted to
he said no you go okay
that makes the moral judgment of people
who have the attraction not act on it
people who have the attraction
makes it a fascinating thought
experiment so one of the most
interesting thought experiments i think
yeah i mean most people have generally
accepted
in
uh
in other contexts that
sexual desire is is amoral
you can't be held responsible for a mere
sexual desire you can only
be held responsible for acting upon it
most people most people think this um
it's one of the the great arguments
in the in the history of
the the liberation of homosexuals has
been
pressing the point that
you don't get to choose to be this way
of course you know with homosexuality
it's a bit easier because you could say
well even if you did there's still no
problem with it it's like yeah even if
you did
even if it were possible to choose to be
a homosexual it wouldn't be wrong to do
so
um but one of the one of the great
points that's pressed is that but it's
even worse because you it's not like you
get to choose this so most people have
accepted that in most contexts but
thinking along these terms
we we begin to think about like
inhibition and so let's think about
somebody who commits a moral crime
and let's imagine a similar kind of
situation let's let's say that whatever
the whatever the moral crime may be take
something that you think is immoral
and they're committing it because
there's a brain tumor that is pressing
against the part of their brain that
deals with inhibition it's now not just
affecting something like attraction or
desire or whatever
it's affecting their actual ability
to suppress
the it to suppress
the basic
uh
sort of
pleasure seeking
crude animalistic tendencies that they
have it's like
okay is that person responsible if i
were to go into your brain personally
and like on purpose
like remove a part of your brain or
press against part of your brain in such
a way that i knew
would make that part of your brain that
that that holds you in moral reprimand
with yourself stopped working such that
the next time you wanted to do something
immoral
you your brain just literally wouldn't
be capable of stopping you because i've
just removed that part of your brain
it's just not there
then you go and commit that immorality
it's my fault
it's not yours you're a victim there
but
again if you find someone who just
naturally
doesn't have
uh
isn't able to control their inhibitions
it's just the way that their brain is
the way that they were brought up which
they had no control over it's their
genetics maybe they've got a brain
injury that's undiscovered or something
who knows but whatever it is
if somebody's not hard-working
somebody's lazy
it's like
okay what if just their brain is just
designed in such a way
that they can't overcome
that laziness can they be held morally
responsible for this kind of stuff in
the same way that we want to say that if
there was a tumor pressing against the
part of your brain that dealt with kind
of your
attractions
we would say you're not responsible for
them and that gives us a reason to think
that you know generally speaking you
can't be held responsible for attraction
it's like
if a tumor pressing against a part of
your brain that dealt with your
inhibitions made you act in particular
ways
then if we if we said that we can say
the same thing we can say well that's
because it's the only reason you're
acting this way is because of something
going on in your brain over which you
have no control it's this
tumor thing that's doing something in
your brain it's like that's how all
action works all the time tuna tumor
tuna or not if you've got tuna in your
breath uh whether you have a tumor or
not at what point does a tumor become a
tumor
something yeah morally responsible for
the way that your brain is made up you
didn't choose your parents you didn't
choose to be born at the time that you
did you didn't choose any of the
upbringings that you have yeah and of
course so this isn't quite a moral
dilemma as much as it's just an argument
against the existence of free will it's
like
any decision that you make seems to be a
result of brain activity over which
ultimately you have no control
i i press this quite strongly i think
that
there is no free will in any actions but
at least in kind of moral the moral
arena people should be able to see that
there's there's a problem here
like
nobody
strictly chooses to be lazy
they just kind of are or maybe they kind
of choose to be lazy and that they they
act in particular ways that bring about
that character but why did they choose
to act in those particular ways
their brain just kind of was of a
psychological constitution that made
them do that
and so if we're going to accept this in
the in the language of desire why not in
the language of action as well why not
in the arena of action how can we say
that anybody's actually morally
responsible for anything at all wasn't
there a guy who had a
he noticed himself getting very
aggressive went up a bell tower started
shooting people after he'd shot his wife
and kids and then finally shot himself
but shot himself in a way that didn't
destroy his brain because he said that
he needed the post-mortem to have a look
he could tell that something was wrong
this was sam harris as well and you'd
think well i mean that's morally
reprehensible but then you go in and
find that there's a tumor the size of a
golf ball in his brain which was
pressing on the amygdala and making him
incredibly angry and incredibly
aggressive and stuff
there is something very very odd when
you think about it was it wrong to kill
those people
yes
is that person responsible for killing
those people
he kind of yes
other gradations of responsibility
yes it seems like there are it seems
like he
is somehow less responsible
than a version of him that did that
without the tumor we go okay well what
if in a different version of this
universe that guy
had a worse upbringing or a more
aggressive father
still no tumor
does aggressive father guy get more of a
pass somehow is he less culpable
should we mediate the
sentences that criminals are given
based on the past that they have
well well sometimes people people think
that we should right like you begin to
feel a bit more
at any rate you wouldn't be surprised to
see like a lawyer
like a defense attorney
arguing in defense of someone who's
committed a crime and pled guilty saying
you know this person has a horrible life
terrible
this kind of thing and and people tend
to be quite uh cold towards that these
these days i i find it's kind of like we
don't care you know they committed a
crime
and and fair enough but i think what
you're getting at by saying
um
what you're kind of getting at is how
much we can separate
him
this person
from
the thing which caused the action like
what is the person like who are you what
makes you you if i just completely
destroyed your brain are you still you
uh maybe not because there's kind of
nothing to call you you've still got
your body still got your biceps still
got your pecs but you're not really
chris
it's like okay well if you have a tumor
and i remove the tumor are you still you
yeah
okay if i removed your upbringing
are you still you
what does that mean
if i gave you my upbringing gave me
yours
like who's who who's chris who's alex
like
starts to get a little bit unclear
what's that
uh paradox of the ship
the ship of theseus the yeah the idea of
if you kind of change uh one plank at a
time you've got this whole ship the ship
of theseus and
you replace a plank because it gets old
starts molding so you replace the one
plank it's still the same ship she's got
a new plank and then you replace another
plank and then another one and then
another one and then another one and
every time you do it it's still the same
ship
but it's just got a new plank on it and
our human bodies do the same thing our
atoms replace each other about every
seven years as a lot of people know
seven years ago you had no atoms in your
body that are in your attitude that
they're in your body right now
um
but imagine once we've replaced every
single plank on the ship of theseus and
we've still got this ship it's still
been in constant use every single day
we take all the planks that were that
were discarded and we build another ship
out of it which one is the ship of
theseus
who knows right it's like
what does it mean to say a person is a
person and i think a lot of people would
say that your history or upbringing is
at least very important in determining
who you are as a person in a meaningful
sense
in the kind of senses that that that we
need here and so this is where we get
this idea of the real self view of the
susan susan wolf is that
there are certain kind of things which
regardless of how in control you are of
of of them
seem to be more your real self
than not so for example if
if you like
tripped over and pushed me into traffic
by accident
you know that that's not your fault
you're not morally responsible
if you were to just push me into traffic
because you thought it was funny
well on this view of there being no free
will you're still not morally
responsible it's not your fault you had
the kind of brain that find that funny
and couldn't couldn't stop the
inhibition
but
that seems more tied to like being an
essential property of you rather than
just an accidental one
you know tripping over people people
trip over and i've got no reason to
think that i'm kind of in danger or that
i've got a problem or that i'm going to
be i'm going to suffer when i'm around
you if you trip up and push me into
traffic whereas if you do it because you
think it's funny
i still don't think you're morally
responsible
but i think that that kind of behavior
is more essentially
springing from your nature and so when
deciding whether to be your friend
which crudely might be some kind of sort
of as some kind of like social contract
that we enter into to
to put your welfare over that of the
strangers and this this kind of thing
it's a bit um unromantic to describe
friendship in that way but but that's
essentially what we're doing it's like
these are the kinds of things which in
which inform it
take take somebody who
is
criminally predisposed because of some
well recognized mental disorder
everybody agrees it's not their fault
that they have a promise to committing
evils
but we know that they're going to commit
a bunch of evils
we probably still want to confine them
you probably still want to put them in
some kind of jail or asylum or something
maybe something a bit nicer maybe we put
them in somewhere where they're where
they're kind of confined they're
separated from society they can't harm
people
but they're kind of treated nicely
they're kind of they're treated
comfortably because it's not quite their
fault that they're there but we still
separate them out and if there's any
chance that we can sort of
change them in such a way that they
might be able to re-enter society if we
can kind of teach them if we can
solve the problem that's going on in
their mind then then maybe we should do
that it's like
this seems plausible
this seems to make sense okay in in in
situations of obviously not being
someone's fault something going on in
their brain maybe the kind of person who
has one of those tumors
if they're gonna if someone's got a
tumor that's causing them to like
sexually assault children like yeah we
should we should we should lock them up
but we probably shouldn't put them in
some concrete cell
and restrict their meals and treat them
horribly because we think it's not
really their fault so we put them in a
bit of a nicer environment and if
there's a way to get rid of the tumor we
try to do it
okay so people often often want to ask
if there's no free will then how do you
deal with responsibility well take this
real self-view and just imagine
that every time like like when you push
me into traffic because you think it's
funny whatever it is in your brain
that's making you do that i kind of
imagine it as being analogous to the
tumor so i think well if you're going
around pushing people into traffic i
should put you in some form of like
jail but maybe not like a really
horrible jail with with concrete walls
but something a bit nicer and and if i
can remove that tumor that is if i can
rehabilitate you
then we should do so
and so what you land upon is a
rehabilitative
view of justice which is quite popular
even among people who do believe in free
will the idea that even the worst kinds
of criminals
should be put into rehabilitative
centers where they're not treated
horribly you know where they have where
they have a level of comfort and if
possible an ability to rehabilitate them
so people are sympathetic to that view
of rehabilitative justice i think
they're already kind of getting towards
the intuition that i have about uh
our moral assessment of responsibility
it's like yes you are responsible
but you're responsible in the way that a
tornado is responsible for uh knocking
down a city it is responsible for it but
it's not morally responsible for it does
this not undermine a lot of people's
intuitions around morality and where
good and bad come from yes it completely
destroys it i mean
moral responsibility
as traditionally thought of is
it just disappears if there's no
free will meaningfully you can't be held
morally responsible you can only be held
sort of descriptively responsible and we
can only react to your behaviors based
on whether we based on our assessment of
whether that behavior is part of your
real self or some accidental quality
that's unlikely to repeat itself and
it's that that we use to inform whether
we want to put you in jail or not
this has got nothing to do with
retribution but if you look at a lot of
the debate around the nature of the
criminal justice system
a lot of people are beginning to see a
lot of problems with
retributive justice anyway they think it
doesn't work they think it's it's it's
not it's not morally right it depends on
what work means right
what are you trying to optimize for are
you trying to send a signal to other
criminals that they shouldn't do this
because it is
more likely to dissuade a future
potential criminal if they know that the
punishment is going to be harsh than if
it's going to not be harsh are you
trying to create some sort of sense of
closure
or
fairness
for the
friends and family of the victim yeah we
recently had this big school shooting in
the state where we are now texas and
it's
let's say that the perpetrator hadn't
been killed but he was still alive
it would be very very difficult to go to
those families
and say well
the thing here is that
retributive justice kind of doesn't
really make any sense this person
although he may have been in conscious
control of the things that he was doing
he didn't really have any will he could
not have done otherwise
therefore
we think that it's a good idea to
put him into a nice jail and
i think that people's uh
emotions
and their sense around how they feel
about something something should be done
this person deserves to pay you know you
hear this sort of language used a lot
yes but of course it would be equally
difficult to
to explain that to to people
if it was discovered that he had a tumor
that was causing him to act in the way
that he did
it'd still be very difficult to ex to
explain that it would be difficult to
swallow but i think if you did that
if you said look this person had a tumor
in their brain that was causing them to
act this way
some people might still say well you
know screw it he still you know deserves
punishment but i think at least
some contingent of those people would be
more likely to say
oh
how does this affect your moral
assessment and crucially
why
why does that make a difference
well this is the basis of the insanity
plea right that there is a
lower degree of culpability for
something that someone's done because of
a clinical diagnosis that makes their
standards for behavior different to your
standards for behavior it's basically
highlighting that's a person
that you can't extrapolate out what you
think good and bad behavior is for
yourself onto that they're in a
different category somehow but of course
the only thing that that should that
that should affect
is the retributive part of the justice
of course by pleading insanity what
you're trying to do is separate the
person from their insanity you're saying
there's this real person this real self
that wouldn't do this and the insanity
is one of their accidental properties
it's not an essential property but an
accidental property and it's the
insanity that's caused the crime so you
attribute the crime to the accidental
property
and not to the real self and so you say
the real self
isn't responsible and so the real self
shouldn't get punished
it's like
okay that that seems to make sense but
it wouldn't affect
how much we want to separate them from
society it wouldn't affect how long we
keep them locked up it wouldn't affect
that we keep them under lock and key in
the first place we would just think well
we're going to do that but now we're
thinking of it in terms of kind of
prevention rather than retribution and i
think that any time you closely analyze
what's going on
with with behaviors like it always makes
sense to think in terms of prevention
and deterrence rather than retribution
and this is something people are
beginning
beginning to see
um
in that retributive justice is very much
going out of fashion but like of course
this is human intuition that says if
somebody commits a horrible crime they
deserve to be punished but
we've got to think about why it is that
people why does that people think that
why that's developed i mean that itself
evolutionarily is probably itself a
deterrence tool
right because if people who commit bad
actions get punished
then
other people are less likely to do them
and before we have a criminal justice
system the way that people get punished
is by vigilantism and vigilantism only
exists if you have people who are just
infused to
harm this person in response to them
being harmful and so you have this very
natural
pre-rational
possibly even pre-human disposition
to think people are morally responsible
and to want them to suffer
for suffering's sake because they caused
suffering but i think that if we're
going to
try to be consistent with our view of
how
the brain works at least and of course
you can just reject this entire view you
can say no free will does exist it does
exist and there's an improper analogy
being given here that's fine but if you
accept the view that we're playing with
here i think you have to be consistent
and say that that retribution is a is is
a lost cause
what's next
what is next
um okay there's there's something else
we can ask that that's along the same
lines let's talk a bit more about this
this idea of kind of
things that you have that you you aren't
really responsible for um
do you think it's unfair
that people
will get admitted to good colleges like
harvard or oxford and cambridge
because they have a lot of money in
their family that is
yes yeah yeah they're able to pay for
like top tier tuition that other people
don't get they're able to pay to go to
private schools they basically pay their
way into these colleges so you're
talking about
money being used to give the person that
is applying a step ahead not money that
is being used to get in the side door by
backhanding it to some administrator
that's right right yeah uh still
my intuition is yes seems seems unfair
it seems like maybe it's not the kind of
unfairness that we could kind of like
legally rectify because that would have
a wealth of implications for you know uh
individual liberty and
uh property and spending your money in
this kind of thing but it seems at least
sort of undesirable
that people should be able to should be
able to do that because of course they
didn't choose to be born with a lot of
money and so yeah they get this
wonderful tutoring they get a a big
house with no worries and a stable
family and they're able to study in
peace and calm while their mate does the
washing up for them whatever it's like
this is unfair that for that reason they
end up going to harvard for that reason
they get a high paying job and the cycle
just continues
okay why then
is it more fair
for somebody to get into harvard
or to oxford or to cambridge because
they're clever
that person didn't choose to be born
with you know a high iq they didn't
choose to be born in a situation
with the kind of upbringing that made
them interested that made them want to
read they didn't choose the desires they
had in the interest they didn't choose
to take an interest in physics when they
were like seven
they just did
but by doing so they end up going to
harvard and by doing so they end up
getting a well-paid job and so
why is one more fair than the other we
want to say that sort of paying away
into college this way is unfair because
they're getting in because of the amount
of money they have not because of their
merit not because of how intelligent
they are
but why is it any more fair to let
someone in based on their merit or
intelligence well when you realize that
merit and intelligence is an endowment
genetically as opposed to an endowment
financially
okay
it feels like there's
i think the intuition is there's
something more selfie
about the
uh
the the brains and the conscientiousness
again also wildly heritable
um i had this discussion a little while
ago it's very interesting talking with a
behavioral geneticist who is uh quite
progressive so she's on the left side of
the aisle behavioral genetics has been
very much adopted by people that are on
the right
and i was asking how do you square this
circle between wanting
um
equal access to opportunity even perhaps
a little bit of equity as well in terms
of equitable outcomes
when you know that people are entering
this race in different ways how
if you were to
flatten out
all
of the opportunity
equalities if you were to get to a stage
where everybody's
level of preparedness was exactly the
same
what you're left with the differences
that occur are now genetic
i mean that's even more brutal you're
saying to somebody the reason that you
didn't get into college yes is
exclusively because your parents have
shitty genetics quite
they had the same diet growing up they
had the same access to sunlight they
were given the same primary all of that
stuff
so okay we flattened society down to
give everybody equal opportunity of of
uh
learning and and food and nutrition and
stuff okay that leaves all differences
now down to nature
how ugly is that to look at that doesn't
seem like a very fair world yeah it kind
of makes it almost even worse i mean if
you don't get into college and someone
says well hey man like you know it it's
it it's it's your upbringing it's
because it's because you didn't have the
money like if you'd have had a bit more
money better resources maybe you could
have made it it's like man that sucks
but okay but if someone says like hey
man you didn't get into harvard and
there's nothing you could have done
about that you are just too stupid it
seems so much worse you're not wired for
this yeah and so like
in other words when somebody says
you know this person paid their way in
you know they didn't get in in because
of their merit because of their
intelligence it's like
why are you saying that with an angry
face why is that any better or worse
it's like well okay maybe a college's
job is just to pick those who are just
actually
you know best suited for study because
we want people in
the
high-paying jobs that are going to be
efficient because it's going to you know
help the economy or whatever it's like
fine but people who pay themselves into
good tuition are by the time they get to
college age like
better suited
to study a course they're going to get
better grades they're going to do the
job better it's like
but it seems to be like an unfairness
about this sure there's an unfairness
about this but there's an unfairness
about the intelligence that either
you're born with if it is genetic or if
it's not genetic even the kind of
upbringing and surroundings that you
have and the interests that you develop
you don't get to control this kind of
stuff so how is that any more fair
so in other words if we're going to
criticize one why don't we criticize the
other it's another slight ethical qualm
and there are different interpretations
you can take this you could either say
okay then maybe it just is unfair to let
people into college based on their level
of aptitude and so we should just be
basically letting anybody into college
for any reason which is kind of the
approach that's being taken not by like
most universities like individually like
the like the harvards and the officers
of the world they still have interview
processes and they're still selective
but there are so many universities now
that basically anybody can go to a
university if they want to and this most
people think is a good thing it's like
yes it kind of doesn't matter where
you're at doesn't matter what you want
to study it doesn't matter how
intelligent you are it doesn't matter
how apt you are like there's going to be
a course that's going to be suitable for
you and you're going to be able to go
and have this experience this is great
and it seems it seems kind of more fair
so you can you can take this approach of
saying well yeah maybe we should just
extend that logic and say that the
harvards and the oxfords of the world
need to abolish the interview process
and basically just select people at
random or something tyler cowan
literally said this the other day he
said that he feels like the selection
process isn't necessarily selecting for
things that
are uh useful long term um that you're
selecting for people who have got great
rote memorization but also are
incredibly orderly they're also the sort
of people that will stick to rules and
he is a disrupter
and he wants to see more people that
would break the rules that would
probably struggle with homework that
would not turn up on time that would do
a lot of the things
that universities want to see
but the problem being
that that undermines the person's
ability to perform in the university and
what you end up with is
trying to change the definition of a
university it's like what what are the
outcomes that we want here he wants to
have people that are
prepared to move humanity forward and
businesses in interesting and novel ways
you know well maybe that's not the job
of a university
so maybe you need something which is not
a university now to prepare people to do
that you go well maybe you're trying to
retrofit
an existing establishment to now
produce people in a different way to the
way that you actually
want them to be crucial i mean the the
the defining factor here is going to be
what is the university like what's it
for
is it
is it like a societal tool to make
people apt for jobs is it a tool to give
people a life experience
is it like is it a qualification machine
like
what is it is it is it something for
kind of private individuals who are
interested in academia to go and find
somebody to study under for the for the
sheer love of knowledge well that seems
to be how they started but that's not
what they are anymore they seem a lot
more kind of institutionalized
embedded into society as a whole like
that's why we have governmental student
loan schemes because the government sees
universities as like a
an important part of society when they
were founded originally kind of as a
just a way for people to to learn stuff
just for the for the sake of it like the
nature of university is always changing
and maybe we just begin to see that
change but of course that's only one
response to this problem you could just
go the other way as well and say
well then yeah if it's fair to admit
people based on their merit it's fair to
admit people based on you know how much
money they've had to to put into private
tuition and things like this and if how
much money somebody the problem with
doing that
because put in those terms it doesn't
seem so bad it's like yeah okay a caller
should have the right to choose someone
who's most apt and sure it's a bit
unfair that someone's paid for tuition
but they've still been you know they've
still had the teaching and they are
actually better now
so maybe it makes sense for the college
to accept them problem with that view is
that of course
the amount of money that somebody has
can become a reliable statistical
indicator of how apt somebody is if
you've got a bunch of applicants you
don't have time to interview everybody
you could think well those with more
money probably paid for private tuition
probably going to be more apt and so a
college would have warrant to start
accepting people without even even
interviewing them just on the basis of
their bank account that seems
problematic
but why you can't do it on the basis of
bank account why can you do it on the
basis of intelligence
if we get into this idea of saying that
you're actually equally responsible for
either
you are as responsible for the amount of
money that you have in your bank account
when you're born as you are for the
intelligence that you have when you're
born
there seems to be a bit of a problem
here there's a book by uh the harvard
professor michael sandel called the
tyranny of merit which seeks to
undermine the entire idea of meritocracy
on these grounds he says like yeah sure
we don't live in a meritocracy but but
so much of politics is basically saying
we you know this is aristocracy or this
is people buying their way into politics
and the implications like we want
meritocracy you know this isn't this
isn't meritocratic is it aristocratic
and michael sandel's like okay cool so
let's like imagine a perfectly
meritocratic society that everyone wants
it's like it's actually still got a
bunch of problems it's still completely
unfair it's still just as morally
arbitrary as aristocracy is there's
something wrong with aristocracy there's
something wrong with meritocracy as well
it's a it's a pretty kind of depressing
revelation but it's it's a book that's
worth reading if people are interested
in this line of thought because we
haven't really gone deep enough they're
probably people listening thinking like
what
the
what are you talking about
are you talking about like the amount of
money that you have
being like
like having the same justification as
how like intelligent you are still
getting into college like
i hope most people can understand why
we're getting at that
but if you want to go further the
tyranny of merit will help to explain it
i also had him on my podcast so if
people want to go and
listen to that then they're welcome to
do so as well what's next
what is
next
indeed okay here's a question for you um
do you think that
if there's like a shortage of treatment
if there's limited funds in like a
hospital
should non-smokers get priority for lung
cancer treatment
no
why non-smokers are smokers non-smokers
that is
sort of there's limited resources
limited money you've got a bunch of
people who need lung cancer treatment
some people have lung cancer because
they've smoked cigarettes all their
lives knowing that there was a great
risk of getting lung cancer some people
have never smoked cigarettes in their
life probably due to the fact that they
wanted to avoid getting lung cancer but
they got it anyway is one more deserving
of the treatment
well i think yes but the question is
should we prioritize treatment for those
who
did not smoke
my
visceral intuition is yes
sure
but probably not
why'd you say probably not
because
the
judgment that the people who smoked made
you don't know if they perhaps had
a genetic predisposition perhaps the
smoking contributed nothing to the fact
that they have lung cancer perhaps all
every single person that didn't smoke
also decided to sit on the couch and eat
and every other smoker was an endurance
athlete that had dedicated their lives
to being fit and healthy apart from
their smoking
it seems like
there is a culpability of
people who do a thing which then causes
a thing to themselves to happen
uh that we're sort of playing off the
back of here
yes um of course i mean imagine for
example that we could prove somehow
through some developed technology that
yes you this person got lung cancer
because they smoked fine give it to them
give it to the mate give it to the
non-smoking mate they get all the
treatment
do you really think that no
okay well let's entertain the idea a lot
of people intuitively think that that
might be a good idea it seems fair it
seems unfair that somebody should like
have to wait in line
for
their lung cancer treatment when the
people in front of them in the line are
people who are there because they smoked
cigarettes for their lives it would be
kind of rage inducing and so we might
think that we should we should do that
of course
there are problems with this because you
have to draw a line of as you say you
have to kind of draw this line of
culpability
i mean
there are kind of all kinds of ways that
can contribute towards a kind of a kind
of life maybe if you
don't drink enough milk
you or or indeed don't eat the the
requisite amount of plant-based
alternatives you don't have sufficient
calcium
and so your bones are more likely to
break they're a bit more brittle
and so you you end up breaking your
ankle one day or something and you go to
the hospital and there are lots of
people with broken ankles
you know should the doctors kind of take
a survey and say well you know this
person has kind of looked after their
calcium and take all their life and they
just fell down a hole and broke their
leg
you've had a calcium deficiency that
you've known about and haven't bothered
to solve and you've broken your ankle
but like you made poor life choices that
have led to this and so we should
prioritize treatment for others it's
like
still like
maybe that kind of makes sense we still
think yeah maybe that's fair but it's
less obviously fair
that somebody should kind of somebody
with a calcium deficiency
should
not be prioritized in getting treatment
whether the person who didn't have the
or who had the calcium deficiency knew
that by not drinking milk yes that it
would contribute so there's culpability
a few layers down yeah of course we know
that
sitting down for too long is bad for us
we know that living a sedentary
lifestyle is
is bad for us but
it's like okay maybe i sit down more
than most people you know i'm a
podcaster i'm a youtuber i spend a lot
of time behind a desk spend a lot of
time in front of a camera
it's like i kind of know this is
probably quite bad for me it's probably
quite bad for my back
okay so i get a back injury i go to the
hospital and someone says well how much
time do you spend sat down every day
it's like well i this is my job i sit
down all the time it's like could you
have stood up more and
stretched your back it's like yeah i
probably could have done well then it's
kind of your fault i've got another
person here who's got a back injury but
they're really healthy they stretch
every day and do yoga and they put a
back injury so they need to you know
skip the cue in front of you
hmm
starting to get a bit
murky
here and if if you begin to take into
consideration
the fact that
we know that all kinds of our behaviors
mildly contribute to various things like
you know if cracking your knuckles
contributes to arthritis which we don't
know whether it does or not but you know
maybe it does it was that guy that did
one experiment right yeah one hand for
instance a lot of people think that this
kind of disproved the thesis because he
cracked his hands and i i can't remember
what happened but i i think it's
possible that he just didn't develop
arthritis at all which of course doesn't
settle the question also it's just like
one guy but like you know credit to him
i think that's a that's fair
to spend your life but it's
it's hard to say whether it does or not
but if it does if someone's just kind of
just does it you know naturally just has
a kind of habitual
click
um
you know should they be not prioritized
for arthritis treatments like
what because they kind of sit around
clicking there well everyone everyone
clicks their their fingers you know
everyone does that well not everyone
does there'll be someone who doesn't and
maybe they should be brought to the
front of the queue if you start
administering medical treatment
on the basis of desert
you're going to end up in this whirlwind
of of
uh of course there's an epistemic
problem of trying to work out who has uh
certain issues because of particular
lifestyle choices but supposing we could
just know all of that there still just
seems to be something callous and wrong
about it it seems to restrict your
freedom too much because there's a point
at which you could just like you could
say that basically any behavior you you
you partake in that isn't perfectly safe
is contributing to this i mean if you
get hit by a car because you cross the
road
and another person gets hit by a car
because the car swerved into the
pavement
it's like sure crossing the road
is more dangerous you chose to do that
you could have not crossed the road it's
like yeah but come on clearly like this
isn't the way that we should be
administering uh
our medical priority but then this
should apply writ large so when you have
the smoker and the non-smoker and they
both need lung cancer treatment
it's a kind of difficult pill to swallow
but it seems like we have not not
sufficient warrant to prioritize one or
the other that's not to say that one
doesn't deserve it more than the other
but
you know it's not always the case that
what a person deserves is what they
should get in practice we saw this
during covid right that there was
different ethnic groups or different
sized groups that were being put to the
front you go well is there something
different between saying that fat people
should get
covered treatment ahead of black people
or black people ahead of white people
and there's an interesting uh sort of
distinction here because the skin color
is more innate whereas the
although there are heritable
characteristics when it comes to your
body weight that seems to be more people
feel like that's more of a lifestyle
choice yeah notice how people were
saying like
uh
well you know there aren't that many
kind of covert casualties and people say
well they're actually there actually are
they look at all these examples and
people said yeah but they all had
pre-existing conditions like
co-morbidities yeah a lot of them a lot
of them were fat you know
and that's kind of like you know they
shouldn't have been fat it's like
can we really say that that
like it's sure like you know that that
not looking after your weight is going
to bring on a lot of health issues but
you certainly didn't know it's going to
give you covert 19 because that wasn't
even a thing like a few years ago and
it's like
it does seem
callous too callous to me to say
something like
okay yeah people are dying of covet but
it's only people who are overweight and
they basically chose that lifestyle it's
like this isn't how we should be doing
medicine leo kirsch said that
kovid was basically enacting tory policy
by killing the old and the fat and the
poor and that at the next general
election he was going to vote for kovid
but yeah i think that
it was very interesting and people were
up in arms about that people are up in
arms about the fact that in america they
were talking about racially uh
prioritizing people but you think well
black people did have the um
i think it's a
lower levels of b vitamins d vitamins
and then they have a genetic
uh marker that changes the way that
their lungs actually absorb viruses so
it meant that they were able to take on
a higher viral load you okay i mean
that doesn't feel like it was their
choice doesn't
that that feels like
they're
a vulnerable
a vulnerable population in a way that
they didn't choose
and that
feels different to the
fat people
somehow i mean i i i don't know
if if that's true i can't verify because
i i i absolutely actually haven't heard
that discussion but you know yeah say it
is
yeah the the idea that like
well
for people who are overweight it's it's
kind of more their fault and so we
should feel less sorry for them or
something like this or we should feel
less bad about the fact that covet is is
is making them into casualties
i i've heard this kind of line of
thought a lot during the cover pandemic
and i kind of i understand why people
are saying it they're saying look i have
to stay inside now because of a virus
that isn't going to harm me
i'd be fine if i got covered but i'm
staying inside to protect wider society
which means the vulnerable which
includes some groups who are vulnerable
through their own life choices that's
not fair but this is a similar line of
thought of being stuck in the queue for
lung cancer treatment and saying i now
have to like wait i i'm now being like
non-prioritized because i'm behind
somebody in a queue who also has lung
cancer but they've got lung cancer
because of their life choices that's not
fair it's the same kind of thought
that's going on and i understand it
because if i was stood in that queue
with lung cancer i'd be annoyed too
but what's the solution here well we
jump people up to the front we allow
people to
come out of their homes is the analogy
here which allow people to come out of
their homes and you know if the fat diet
the fat diets for their own life choices
and if the people with lung cancer die
and i don't well that's because they
smoked and i didn't and that's that's
fine they deserve it but as i hope you
can see from our previous discussion
here like again by kind of reductio ad
absurdum it's like okay well let's take
that line of logic and apply it to all
medical procedures across the board not
just the obvious ones but the more
subtle ones not just the ones that
involve smoking or becoming obese the
ones that involve sitting down for too
much per day or participating in too
many extreme sports or this kind of
thing it doesn't seem to be as as
intuitively obvious and so i think
look i get it i get why you're saying
that i get why you're frustrating it is
frustrating
but
this is not an appropriate response to
the situation it's not appropriate to
then say well sure okay let's just like
let the fat die or let's let the lung
cancer
patients who got there by smoking keep
their lung cancer i just don't think
this is the way that it that medicine
should be administered of course you
might disagree with me here but this is
the nature of an ethical dilemma it's
not supposed to be an ethical monologue
but a
but a dilemma indeed and i'm interested
to hear what your viewers think as well
you got any left you got one more the
only thing that i think should get a
mention perhaps here is that we've
kind of been assuming we've essentially
been assuming atheism here we've been
assuming uh ethical theories that don't
involve the numinous um but there are
yeah you know i'm trying to the numinous
or the
the i'm trying to kind of find a word
that pins down this idea of god that
doesn't pin us to a particular god or
religion so something about there being
a supernatural element yeah it's a it's
a wonderful word that's often used to
describe this kind of
um
untouchable uh supernatural element like
the when you
when you listen to music and you kind of
feel something a bit kind of a bit above
you a bit of material maybe that's the
that's the numinous if you if you see if
you're looking at a piece of art and you
begin to see the artist through the
artwork maybe that's the that's the
numinous um rudolph rudolph otto the the
famous theologian
could find no better word to describe
the religious experience than the latin
formulation of mysterium tremendous at
fascinans
a mystery that at once makes you tremble
but is also fascinating it's it kind of
pushes you away it's scary but it also
pulls you in at the same time it's
actually famously difficult to pin down
the nature of religious experience but
the most famous just to give it some um
you know air time because there are a
lot of religious people in the world
after all
the the biggest ethical dilemma that
that somebody who thinks that ethics is
grounded in god has is known as the
euthyphro dilemma comes from plato's
euthyphro a dialogue in which the
question is is basically asked we'll
reword it slightly but we say okay
things okay things are good and they're
somehow grounded in in god
the things that are good are they good
because god commands them
or does god command them because they're
good
well let's consider either option let's
say god commands them because they're
good
this means that there's a standard of
good that exists outside of god which
god is subject to and so if god is
supposed to be the grounding of of
ethics that's not going to work
okay let's say that they're good because
god commands them
fine then what if god commanded that
rape was ethical what if god commanded
you to shoot up a school
what if god commands you to sacrifice
your own child well we know what
christianity teaches and indeed islam
that one should do
because we have the story of abraham who
was told to sacrifice his child and of
course his hand is steadied at the last
moment
but the fact that he was willing to do
the sacrifice is something that
celebrated in fact the the islamic
festival of edel ada
is celebrating that particular event
abraham's willingness to sacrifice his
own child
because god told him to
but this seems like a pretty difficult
pill to swallow okay things are good
because god commands them you're
committed to the view that if god
decided to command that rape was ethical
it would just become ethical and so it
become trivially true that no matter
what god commanded you to do you ought
to do it there's nothing wrong with this
per se there's nothing inconsistent or
contradictory about it but it seems
troubling
and so the euthyphro dilemma has been
kind of discussed to no end
and there are some people who think it's
a false dichotomy some people say
well god just is good which i'm never
quite sure exactly how that solves the
problem but this is a dilemma that needs
to be discussed as well because even as
a theist even thinking that there's an
all-powerful god you might be troubled
at the fact that the objectivity that
you seek to find
in
religious morality
collapses into something like divine
subjectivity
it's it's just kind of still just an
agent
deciding on their own whim essentially
what's good and what's bad you've just
moved the subjectivity from within
yourself to within this god
and if you want to retain some
objectivity that even that god is bound
by well then god isn't the ground of
ethics in the first place as i say this
is this is an ancient dilemma and it's
not seriously troubling to most people
who've thought about it deeply who are
religious because they've got an answer
to it but it's one of the first dilemmas
that i think needs to be thought about
if if there are any religious listeners
or indeed if there are just people who
are not religious but interested in
dilemmas for religious ethics too so
there are dilemmas across the board
alex arcana ladies and gentlemen if
people want to follow the stuff that you
do if they've enjoyed what you've been
talking about today where should they go
uh they should go to patreon.com cosmic
skeptic and give me all their money
no they should they should find me a
cosmic skeptic uh across the board it's
quite a unique name so youtube twitter
facebook where should they start
talk what video on youtube would you get
them to start with depends what they're
interested in uh i do a lot of vegan
advocacy people are interested in that
my favorite video on that that i've ever
made is the worst of cognitive
dissonance um but apart from that i'm
quite proud of some of the podcasts that
i have uh that i've put together
for philosophy of religion i did a
podcast with william lane craig where we
discussed the cosmological argument and
that alex alex alex that that argument
goes into the list of things so stupid
that i couldn't even believe that it was
said by somebody yeah that's a real
that's a that's a real genuine quote um
i was quite i was quite proud to defend
the argument that he said was part of
his list of arguments so bad he couldn't
have made them up and i think that i
actually still defended it i think it
was being a little bit unfair there but
that was a wonderful uh that was one of
my favorite podcasts so uh yeah depends
what you're interested in but i'd
certainly recommend starting on youtube
all right man i appreciate you thank you
for coming to see me in austin and uh
i'm looking forward to the next one
already of course me too what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace